ce jeudi 15 juin 7h 45 devant les portes
du lycée emilie de breteuil de montigny
le bretonneux ces étudiants en terminale
sont tous venus avec une convocation
dans les mains et une bonne dose de
stress dans leur sac pour passer leur
baccalauréat
au total ils seront 300 ha élèves toutes
filières confondues a planché sur la
première épreuve la philosophie du show
la philo j'avoue que j'ai pas trop
révisé mais bon j'ai du talent un garçon
talentueux la philo c'est décontracté un
peu si je dois cette épreuve là je pense
que baky sinon ça va aller une fois dans
l'établissement les élèves sont répartis
dans une vingtaine de sel à 8 heures les
couloirs qui grouille et d'étudiants
sont désormais désert pour laisser place
à la concentration une atmosphère
studieuse que la direction du lycée
connaît bien c'est quand même un examen
un examen important c'est d'une certaine
façon la fin de leur scolarité pour
beaucoup mais bon ils sont préparés tout
au long de l'année donc il n'y a pas de
raison que ça se passe pas bien
après la distribution des copies les
élèves ont pu disserter pendant quatre
heures sur la raison le droit la liberté
l'art et la culture à la sortie premier
bilan
je pense que j'ai fait à quelque chose
d'assez correct quand même je me
souviens suis pas trop mal sorti donc
donc ça va je pense que c'est je pense
que je crois on se douche je pense que
ça ses objectifs
au début j'ai lu le texte rejeté un peu
paniqué puisque j'avais pas du tout
compris mais après j'ai relu deux trois
fois après j'ai fait un brouillon sapin
fin de ma vie que j'ai fait un brouillon
et ça m'a plutôt aider du coup cette
débrouillons un nouvel ascenseur
émotionnel est programmée pour ce
vendredi ce joint la 208e édition du
baccalauréat continuera avec les
épreuves d'histoire géographie pour les
filières générales